salut romain ça ouah tu manges une
tartiflette n'ont pas enlevé tes
chaussures changer de parfum battant et
un truc là tu as fait quelque chose
abbas cherche pas georges passer ça
[Musique]
avoir les oreilles percées qui pue on
n'en parle pas trop parce que bon c'est
pas le genre de truc qu'on a envie de
mettre sur son cv ou sur son profil
twitter
mais en réalité c'est hyper courant
c'est même tellement fréquent qu'en
anglais il ya une expression pour ça on
parle de here she is du fromage
d'oreille
c'est marrant hein dès qu'on a un organe
qui suit est une matière des gueux qui
pue on appelle ça du fromage bah si
comme comme le fromage de bon ok bref en
tout cas pour les oreilles
c'est un fait établi ça existe mais
pourquoi ça sont comme ça eh ben ça
[Musique]
quand on se perd ses oreilles on se fait
un trou dans le corps là où il y en a
pas normalement
alors nos autres orifices disons-le et
physiologiques
on pense à les nettoyer parce que sinon
ils finissent par sentir mauvais voilà
c'est pareil sauf que 1
on n'y pense pas forcément et 2 c'est
pas facile d'accès pour connaître en
vrai dans un premier temps on pense à
les nettoyer on les désinfecte même le
temps que ça cicatrise
mais c'est après que ça se gâte on se
laisse un peu aller on néglige son trou
et il se met à sentir mauvais vous savez
je vous vois ricaner chaque fois que je
parle de 38 sont mauvaises pour savoir
pourquoi ça semblait il faut d'abord
savoir ce qu'il ya dedans
ce que je vous propose c'est ni plus ni
moins que de vous donner la recette du
fromage d'oreille
[Musique]
approchez-vous je vais vous mettre dans
la confidence
mais ce qu'il faut savoir avec ce
procédé fait qu'il ait tendrement rayé
par les maîtres affineurs qui depuis des
siècles se transmettre le secret voilà
donc vous avez les ingrédients mais je
vous propose de nous attarder deux
secondes sur le processus d'affinage
en fait il se passe dans le trou de
votre oreille la même chose que sous vos
bras ou entre vos doigts de pied je vous
remets dans la description le lien vers
mes vidéos sur les pierres matière
produits par le corps et sur l'hygiène
corporelle
si vous êtes dans un petit rappel en
gros voilà toutes ces substances
elles restent coincés là dedans en plus
de toutes les saloperies qui passe et
puis il ya les bactéries attention à la
on parle pas d'infection on parle des
bactéries qu'on a un petit peu partout
sur la peau et qui squattent dans le
trou parce que elles sont au calme et
deux bouffées gratos bah oui parce que
cette mixture là pour elle c'est de
régalade
du coup bas et mangent et mangent et une
fois qu'elles ont bien mangé
qu'est ce qu'elles font eh ben ils font
comme vous et slash est rouge est ce
dont elles ont pas besoin et ça sent
mauvais alors j'ai bien conscience que
maintenant que vous savez que c'est du
caca de bactéries vous regrettez
peut-être l'époque vous pensiez que
c'était du fromage je suis désolé mais
en même temps c'est toujours mieux de
savoir ne serait ce que pour dissuader
ce qu'on a envie de s'en faire une
tartine c'est pas du fromage alors bon
d'accord c'est normal tout ça mais est
ce que c'est une fatalité d'avoir les
trous d'oreilles qui sont là qu'on
cautionne banon on peut faire des choses
pour éviter ça d'abord choisissez bien
la matière de vos bijoux on supporte
moins bien certains métaux que d'autres
et du coup ça peut sûreté et puis bon je
sais c'est tentant mais est vite
tripoter tout le temps vos bijoux
d'oreilles des bactéries on en a partout
mais on en a surtout sur les mains vous
en déposer un petit peu plus à chaque
fois mais évidemment ça suffit pas le
problème on l'a vu c'est que ça stagne
et que c'est souvent un endroit qu'on ne
nettoie pas donc penser à laver votre ou
d'oreilles avec de l'eau tiède et du
savon doux voire du savon au ph neutre
pour ça a commencé par enlever vos
bijoux et passer un petit coup dessus
aussi
si ça suffit pas vous pouvez utiliser du
savon antibactérien
ensuite pour les trous bon alors allez
pas rentrer des trucs là dedans vous
risqueriez de vous faire mal mais déjà
si vous nettoyez bien les lobs et
l'extérieur des trous en appuyant bien
dessus de chaque côté c'est pas mal et
puis vous pouvez en profiter pour passer
un coup derrière les oreilles
alors c'est pas toujours nickel par la
montée pas et pour finir sachez que même
si vous mettez plus de bijoux ça peut
arriver à des vieux trou malheureux
boucher ne pas sentir très bon vraiment
des gamins voient la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui s'il ya d'autres questions
qui vous titille vous pouvez me les
poser sur facebook twitter instagram ou
à l'adresse question dtc @ gmail point
com on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portée
[Musique]